it's an exclusive interview from someone
with a very unique perspective on the
derrick chauvin trial
lisa christensen was her name is her
name rather she was an alternate juror
so that means she did not have a role in
the verdict but she did sit through
every single minute of the trial as
prosecutors and the defense each
made their case christensen spoke to
jamie yukas
jamie she told you that even though she
wasn't part of the deliberations
she did come to a decision good morning
to you
she absolutely did gail good morning to
you lisa christensen known in the court
as juror 96 told me she was happy with
the jury's decision
to convict derek chovin after weeks of
hard testimony
but says she was reluctant to be on the
jury when she was first called up
you didn't want to be on the jury i was
worried about you know
whatever the verdict may be if some
people felt strongly on one side
other people felt strongly on the other
side
so no matter what i felt felt like
somebody wasn't going to be happy
would you have decided any differently
than this jury did
i um i felt he was guilty
they read the jury instructions to us in
the courtroom
briefly i didn't know if it was going to
be guilty on all counts but
i would have said guilty why did you
think he was guilty what led you to that
belief
i just felt like the prosecution made a
really good
strong argument dr tobin was the one
that really did it for me he explained
everything i understood it
down to where he said this is the moment
that he lost his life
um really got to me so who made an
impact with the defense
um good or bad made it just made an
impact
i don't think they had a good impact i
think he over promised in the beginning
and
didn't live up to what he said he was
going to do or what were your first
impressions of derek chauvin
every time i would look up yes he was
right in my
vision so we had locked eyes quite a few
times and i was pretty uncomfortable
was there anything about him when you
started seeing the videos and the
pictures
that struck you about him i felt like he
was a leader
and and other officers were following
his lead
i kind of felt like he wasn't taking the
warning seriously obviously
kind of like i know what i'm doing which
witnesses stood out to you
miss frazier that took the video i
really felt
that she felt guilty for not doing more
and she feels responsible in a way
and i feel really bad for her but i
commend her on
taking the video because without her
i don't think this would have been
possible so
had you ever seen the nine and a half
minutes of video before no
um i seen i've seen the video two or
three times but i didn't see it in its
entirety because i only saw it on the
news
so what was it like to have to watch it
over and over and over again in court
it was it was emotional um
i think my eyes teared up a couple of
times so
especially seeing it from different
angles and and things
do you feel like that's going to impact
you for a while um
i do so in what way
well i just don't understand how it got
from
a counterfeit 20 bill to a death
it it kind of shocks me
lisa lives in brooklyn center the city
where dante wright was shot by a police
officer nearly two weeks ago
she told me those protests did not play
into her decision
about chauvin being guilty in her mind
wright will be laid to rest today
and the floyd family will be there
anthony and obviously lisa christensen
took her responsibility very seriously
jamie thank you